hello welcome everyone
um so just to start off uh I would like
to acknowledge that the native lands
that this current building resides on
which belong to the Muncie Lenape people
I'm also from New York city so it's also
really interesting to learn about
um the people who used to live here
before we did
um so my name is Daniel Chen I am
currently a postdoctoral research and
teaching fellow at the University of
British Columbia I am also a data
science educator at posit PBC formerly
known as art studio and I currently work
on their Academy team so it's all
education related work that I do I've
been heavily involved with the
carpentries and I'm also the author of a
book called pandas for everyone which I
was just told that they've given me
coffees they give out to folks so
we'll figure some mechanism to give them
away
um so I'm pretty much uh usually go to
like our python conferences and then
usually end up talking about the other
language but I do get to say that there
are actually almost literally a dozen of
our users at this conference uh today so
uh it's kind of nice to see and that's
sort of where this what this talk
revolves around as well
so I'm here to talk to you about quarto
um I am not one of the main core
developers of it I am going to talk to
you as a Avid user slash someone who's
really excited about this tool
and so what is quarto well if we look at
the website I'm just going to Plate rise
off of their definition uh it is a open
source scientific and Technical
publishing site system built on pandok
and what's also really cool is it gives
you the ability to
interweave python code our code Julia
code are observable which is uh
JavaScript
all into a single scientific document
so who would really want to use quarto
so you're either like me you're a data
scientist you do a whole bunch of work
in Jupiter notebooks so that's either
for your analysis or you're trying to
run a report and create some kind of
documentation of what you're doing
uh maybe you're doing some kind of
technical writing so you're trying to
keep a Blog of things that might need
bits and pieces of code uh you want to
host a website either for like a course
a university course or your own personal
website
um presentations like this one that
you're looking at are is written in
quarto
um a lot of documentation for packages
like we just saw from the polars
packages package maintenance are
starting to write books accompanying
their libraries now just as another way
to get users acquainted with their tools
so you can also write books using quarto
and as an academic one of the other
really cool things
um is when you're writing papers there's
actually a very robust citation system
associated with it as well so if you fit
in any of these roles like hopefully
this becomes a tool that you get to look
into
um this is one of the images that I have
from my dissertation actually and really
the the main thing I wanted to point out
here is as data scientists we go through
all of this process of getting data
assessed processing and analyzing it but
really like none of that stuff uh really
matters unless we create something for
the world to ingest and then when the
world ingests the stuff that we create
do keep in mind that like it does
feedback into the world and
um some kind of consequences either good
or bad happen so be very mindful of that
um but a big part of that is you need a
mechanism to communicate those results
and again quarto is one of the tools
that you can do to do that
and another thing so Allison Hill
um probably you know our mainly 3dr
World
um but she has this really funny post
where like she has more websites than
blog posts and again that's really
because uh some of the tools that came
out from the our ecosystem make it
almost too easy to put something on the
Internet
um so
um it just goes to show um how flexible
these tools can be
so now the question is doesn't Jupiter
do that like I talked about Julia python
R and it's like literally in the name
Jupiter like it's supposed to do this
um so the answer is yes but we got to
talk about notebooks first so there is
uh this series of talks over the last
couple of years and if you don't know um
there's links to them on the actual
slide but there was a talk by Joel gross
in 2018 about
things that he doesn't like about
notebooks and then Jeremy Howard replies
back like you know what I actually do
like notebooks um so I do employ you to
take a look at those talks um
just as additional background
information
but here's my list of like what I do and
don't like about notebooks so in
technical writing it's actually really
nice I get to do literate programming so
I can interweave code and prose text and
describe something of what's going on
but then the problem eventually becomes
I need to edit this that's not on my
computer and now I'm faced with this
giant Json blob and I just wanted to put
a period somewhere or like a comma and
now you're editing raw Json putting in
punctuation marks and then you are in a
world for her
um as a data scientist I almost think of
Jupiter notebooks more as an output
format just because figures and tables
and results are all in there which is
good so it's like great when I'm
teaching and I'm running a workshop I
can just code along and talk and then
the output is there and I publish it on
GitHub and it renders and I don't have
to worry about giving my students any
any of the assets that came out of a
workshop
but the second you end up needing a
notebook for a collaborative environment
you're back into okay here's this giant
Json blob uh you hope that there's no
image in there that you have to like
eventually diff and it becomes like a
nightmare
um but the other nice thing that I've
noticed from a teaching perspective
there's actually a lot of really great
teaching tools around Jupiter notebooks
so MB grader is one that we use at UBC
um and one of
um the why I don't like about notebooks
is this notion of
um hidden States and notebooks and what
I've actually found that like if you
tell the students that if the first
thing you do after you run into a
problem is just to go restart kernel run
all
um that usually fixes a lot of the
weirdness that happens with hidden
States because students start executing
code in the wrong order so you just tell
them like here's the way to essentially
turn it off and turn it back on again
and then you come to me with your
question so that's that's sort of the
workaround that we've um that I've done
uh with my students
so okay so this talks about quarto so
quarto versus Jupiter um so here's the
high level like just what the documents
look like on the left hand side you have
a quarto document in vs code
um and now on the right hand side here
is a Jupiter notebook in Jupiter lab
and again the first thing you'll notice
um okay so there's these things that
look like code in cell blocks or
something but the thing that's missing
on the left hand side here is there
isn't like the table output or there
isn't this figure output in there so
that's one of the nice things that I
like about using with quarto documents
is like the output isn't embedded in the
file and it is a plain text file so
that's also really nice too
so
it really isn't that it's quarto versus
Jupiter
um it really becomes like Corto actually
uses Jupiter under the hood so it's not
saying that like one is a totally
different tool that you have to just
give everything up
um if you start off with the quarto
document and if you're rendering or
using code that's anything but R it
actually leverages all of the Jupiter
ecosystem so like all the stuff that you
already have like kind of already is
there
um the only thing that changes later on
down the pipeline is it all goes through
it creates a markdown file and then it
goes through pandok to render into all
of the other data um all the other
output formats so this part right here
is a little bit different from Jupiter
uh and Jupiter notebooks that use like
uh jupit text or you have to write my
structured
my is that the Morton flavor like my St
um so that's the little part that's a
little bit different
um but it still uses the whole Jupiter
ecosystem so I don't want to give the
impression that it's really like you
have to pick quarto and then you have to
give up everything that you've done
um with your Jupiter notebooks
and then just like as another example
um so Jeremy Howard uh who runs fast AI
um they actually use quarto right now um
they actually wrote a whole blog post
about how they're swapping everything to
quarto and they're a very Jupiter
notebook Centric
company and what they do
all right so let's let's go and do an
analysis so you have an example of
what's going on
um so this is something that you might
do typically as a data scientist you
might load some data so here's um from
python there is a package called polymer
penguins that you can use the load
Penguins function to get data about
penguins and this is a regular data
frame it's got mixed type you can see
that there's some numbers there's some
missing values and I have some
categorical values et cetera Etc
and again like this is a presentation
written in quarto and actually when I
rendered the presentation like this is
live executing the code that's presented
here
um so this isn't like a pre-calculated
thing um so when I was editing my slides
right before I came on the stage um
there was also like a risk that
something horrible would have happened
and not rendered so
all right so now let's go do some
exploratory work we can use something
like pandas for that I know like there
was just a talk about polars but here it
is here's then Panda's example we can
run pandas code to get some kind of
overall description
descriptive statistics of our columns
and again this is live executed so you
can see the output and this is in the
presentation format
we can also do plots so here's a
plotting Library
um called plot nine which is sort of so
I also come from the r world so this is
almost copy and paste from ours ggplot
code and so we can actually visualize
um what's going on with our data set and
again the code that we have up here it
can dump the output right below
and then last but not least we always
want to be able to model something so
you can actually
um assuming all your packages are
installed and you kind of know how to
use the modeling functions uh we can
actually create a model and then pull
out some type of the actual coefficients
for this model and then be able to say
something about how does mass affect the
sex of a penguin
so before I continue so like I talked
about models so there is a totally
separate talk about model Ops within
this whole ecosystem that Isabelle is
running tomorrow I think at the same
time today so I'll just give a shout out
to that particular talk
um but now like we have like the basics
um set of things that we want to be able
to do as a data scientist let's go
actually go make things
so we can go create uh what's known as a
quarto markdown document or qmd or we
can actually copy paste all the code and
put it into a regular uh jupyter
notebook so again either one of these
four file formats will work so if you're
again working already in jupyter
notebooks go down the Jupiter notebook
path or you can learn how to create a
chordo document
and so the thing that
um what's part of this quarto document
so at the very top uh you have a yaml
header so on the left hand side like
this is the bare minimum of what you
need you just need to tell it
what output do you want right so it's
pretty typical for a lot of these uh
data science reports to be HTML just so
it's continuously scrolling we don't
have to worry about Pages or stuff like
that
but on the right hand side this is
essentially the uh example uh that I
have in the repository so if you want to
take a look at this these slides there's
an examples folder and this is roughly
what that looks like so you can add more
information
including the ability to keep the
intermediate file so if you really need
to like intercept what gets created
during that whole pipeline you can
actually say like keep the markdown file
that gets generated or keep the actual
notebook file because you have this
whole other process that is notebook
Jupiter Notebook based but you just
don't want to deal with having the
outputs like in line with your file so
there are ability ways to like keep that
stuff so you can sort of ease your way
into this
there's also this line down here that
I'll talk about in a little bit uh you
also need to just say like hey like when
you want me to render this notebook like
what binary do you want me to use to
like execute the non-r cells
so we talked about the ammo file so then
now there is the actual code chunk so
this is a little bit different from what
you're used to when you're working with
Jupiter notebooks so this is what a code
chunk looks like assuming you know how
markdown works and you can know how to
write the pros text around it the code
chunk looks something like this begins
with read back tick so that is markdown
notation for I'm gonna like treat this
as a Verbatim piece of text or code
and then you put into curly brackets and
then this is known as the engine so this
is uh what is the language that you're
going to tell Corto to like execute the
code below so here this is a python
conference so this is a python engine
um in this code block
and then the other cool thing is with
um this special type of comment with a
hash and a bar or and a pipe you can
tweak how that code trunk behaves and
how the behavior changes for the output
so here I'm actually saying Echo equals
true which means when I go and render
this document I actually want you to
show the code so that also implies that
there are ways for you to hide the code
so if you just need a figure without all
of the text for how you generated the
figure you can hide that and it's you
can do that in Jupiter notebooks you
have to again edit the Json file and
hope that you got everything correct but
in here you also get a very quick way to
just say add a whole bunch of other um
parameters or options to your code
and then the rest of the text that's not
in this special comment is regular code
and then so once you have an entire
document that you're ready to do once
you have quarto installed it is a
command line tool so you can actually
run run a command called quarto render
and then give it the qmd file that you
want to render and you'll see here that
like it has detected the fact that like
there are some cells in here that are
not our cells so it's going to use
Jupiter to start executing finding and
executing all of those cells and then
it'll sort of convert everything to
pandok and then a whole bunch of other
stuff and then you end up with this uh
quarto HTML file
I believe that I have open yes so this
is what it looks like
really similar to if you were to export
out an HTML file for a jupyter notebook
so here's some of the metadata
information I had enabled the fact that
there's a table of contents so we can
toggle that around and here's code and
the actual output and this is something
that's really nice when you are trying
to give a report to someone but you
don't want to look at all of the the
artifacts in the middle as you're like
creating this document
and again you can do the same thing with
the Jupiter notebook
um put yourselves take your existing
Jupiter notebook actually like all you
need to do is install quarto and then
just point it to a Jupiter notebook that
you have
if you want it to actually re-run all of
the cells from top to bottom you for a
Jupiter notebook you do have to remember
to put in the flag for execute otherwise
what it will do is just take the jupyter
notebook and whatever you have in there
write it out to the HTML type that's
what we have so there's two ways where
you can if you already have stuff
pre-rendered you can just use quarto as
like hey I want this pretty thing don't
try to execute code you can do that as
well
and the output for this is exactly the
same it'll give you like an HTML file
since that's what we specified
all right so then that's it right like
you you have your thing and then you can
share it with other people
um and that's really nice
okay so you can actually do a lot of
other cool stuff as well so
um
this is not my work but you can actually
put in uh use what a new tool or uh I
guess as a tool called shining for
Python and you can actually embed these
like Widgets or really dashboards like
into a quarto document right so this is
a essentially a really simple dashboard
that is really good at multiplying
things by two and showing it to you but
it's in a quarto document and this is
running python under the hood and it's
also running it under webassembly so it
doesn't it's just it's just doing its
thing
um we just came from a talk
um where Fabio talked about Pi script
and so like everyone went ooh and wow uh
when there was a figure so here's a
figure and we can again create a
dashboard and then straight up embed it
into my presentation and it's all done
through webassembly
and then for one more example because
I went second uh you can actually do
this with maps as well so a lot of other
the plotting libraries
um you can do and again like this is
um able to embed all of this stuff into
a quarto document and then the quarter
document can be rendered into a
presentation or something else so that's
all really cool
but that's not that's not my work Shine
for python is um being being worked on
by Joe Chang and Winston Chang which are
here and then they'll be out on the
booth
um throughout the next couple of days
Joe is giving a talk about shiny for
python specifically later today so if
you're interested about how to make
these types of dashboards in Python like
do not ask me questions about this
yeah
okay so I have to go on a small rant
about uh python itself because we are uh
trying to execute a document that needs
to go find Python and then like do its
calculation and give you results
so this is a really common error that
you'll see
um when you try to quarto render or
preview a document and really it's going
to say like hey I don't know what like
this notebook format is
um like can't find Jupiter like go
install it and like we've probably seen
this error before a bunch of times where
we're like like import pandas and it's
like I don't know what you're talking
about it's like I literally just typed
in those words you told me to type in so
what is going on right
and so
um it is sort of like an ongoing joke
it's very it's it's really there in the
our world but like so the problem is
like there's this notion of like where
is python installed and how did we
install it and then if we want a more
complicated uh project like then we're
dealing with environments so like it's
always a question of like what am I
actually looking at or like when I call
python where is it
um so it is a really big uh problem that
does exist has gotten a lot better
um but it is sort of like one of those
uh ongoing jokes that other languages
like to poke fun of at python so
um
there are a couple of really good
solutions to this
um at pycon this year uh Calvin gave
this really nice talk about using pi M
so if you're on uh anything that's not
Windows Pi M works really well Pi M
actually does have a Windows thing it
just doesn't have all of the plugins
that make it like work really really
nice but what really saved me a lot of
times when I first started data science
on a Windows machine was really was
Anaconda so like these are I would say
like the two big things that I use day
to day
and then just like as a for completeness
um what we use at at least my group at
posit we actually use Pi MV and pip M to
sort of use Python and create the
environments um and then at UBC we
actually everything is like Anaconda
slash conduct based so
so how do we deal with that problem
um
really like your best friend in the
command line is running which python to
give you the binary of like this is
where my python is if you're using
something like Pi M also there's a
command called which versions that
actually tell you if you've opened up a
virtual environment what actual virtual
environment are you actually in
so once you figure it out that like at
least when I called this in the command
line and it's pointed to the right
python what else can go wrong so there's
this other command called core code
check and it will again reply back to
you what quarto thinks is the python
that you're using where the kernels for
your instance are essentially run this
when you go and like post a bug report
or you're asking for help it's a really
really good check literally in the name
for um seeing what what's going on in
your system
the other important thing for me this is
like that error message literally
happened to me because I was in vs code
and so if you're using vs code to edit
quarto or create quarto documents do
remember that vs code has its own
separate option to select python so like
the terminal and vs code does one thing
but then like if you click on buttons
around vs code it is pulling from some
other variable for python so if you are
in vs code again like I think it's
command shift p type in Python select
interpreter and then pick the right
python you think you've just done
um and so that's like the series of of
checks that I always do
um to deal with the Corto can't find the
kernel problem
the other uh sort of difference is when
we are working in a Jupiter notebook uh
typically when we click on file new and
then we get to pick a kernel if you're
working with environments you have to go
through this process of like registering
this kernel in your environment you
don't really need to do that for quarto
um all quarto needs to know is like what
is the environment my python is and then
it really calls like the Python 3 for
that environment so that's where that
line in the yaml header comes in it just
says like it knows what the environment
is because you've said it and then all I
do is call python3 and then it's already
in that environment so you don't have to
run or really remember this command of
setting the IPI kernel installing it et
cetera Etc you don't need to do that all
you need to do is activate your
environment and then it will find things
from there
all right so now what about like all the
other things that you can do
uh around quarto so there is a really
nice gallery
and again like all of this cool stuff
that I talked about at the beginning
where there's articles presentations
documents websites books uh they're all
much much better examples from what I've
like presented myself
um and you can always find that stuff in
the in the gallery
um and then what can you do there's
actually on the actual website there is
a get started guide and it really does
say like step one install the thing step
two what is the main tool that you're
trying to use so if you're starting off
from vs code there's a separate set of
instructions for vs code
um if you're in our studio there's a
couple set up things there most of us
probably are used to just working in
Jupiter so there is another Pathway to
get things done there or you're sort of
like me sometimes where I just need a
text editor and I'm just going to copy
paste commands into the terminal that's
all uh good a fair game and you can do
that
um another cool thing that you can do is
if you have a simple uh presentation one
that's not like mine with a whole bunch
of python stuff and examples in the in
the repo once you create like your
index.um
chordo document
if you enable building sites in GitHub
it will actually auto trigger a CI build
that will render your slides in GitHub
so that's a actually really cool thing
that you can do
um
again my presentation itself is a little
bit more complicated so you have to
actually write the workflow file for for
GitHub to actually render and deploy but
if it's really simple
um that is a really quick way to get
something on the Internet and then auto
update as you're making changes
uh the other thing that you can do is
you can actually go to quartop.com
create an account
and what that will do is it'll give you
a service where you can take any quarto
document that you actually have
created and it will you can run a
command called quarto publish and it
will build the quarto document or
website or project that you have right
now and then send all of that up to
quarto Pub
so all that really needs is make an
account on quarter Pub when you run
quarto publish for the first time it'll
sort of ask you a couple of questions
like
what is your actual username can you
actually log in and then some yes or no
questions to set up a yaml file that it
uses but then you get this like website
that is that exists somewhere
without having to do much work on if you
don't want to set up like a CI instance
on GitHub
and then I'll sort of before I go for
like a really quick set of demos or
anything uh there are a lot of cool
things that you can do so Tom mock uh
probably like if you Google Tom Mock and
quarto there's a whole bunch of stuff
that he has created including a really
thorough Workshop or set of materials
from a workshop that you can go through
Allison Hill actually gave a talk a
couple weeks ago just talking about
notebooks in general
um the the pluses and minuses that you
can deal with notebooks
um Gordon Shotwell gave a talk recently
about uh comparing quarto and Jupiter so
I've sort of discussed a little bit
about like how the two tools are related
and then finally uh at our studio conf
this year one of the Keynotes by uh
Monet and Julia they actually talked
about how
um they use Cordo they share collaborate
and teach reimagine it uses one of the
NASA openscapes projects as the example
so that's a little tie into our keynote
this morning and also it's a really good
talk if you want to actually see the
demo of how citations work within this
ecosystem so if you're trying to do some
type of academic publishing that's a
really good resource there
so I'm gonna try to do a really quick
demo of how this works um but if you
want to take a picture this is probably
the only picture that you would really
need so you can go to quarto.org go
through the get started page there's a
series of guides that let you pick like
what type of project do you want for
example if you wanted to create a
website Cordo actually has a function
called create project
you give it a name and then you give it
like one of the quarto types and it will
just pre-populate the boilerplate folder
structure and all of the the
whatever needs to just get started for
that particular website and and then all
you need to do is say quarto preview and
then whatever project that's in there
will sort of render out so let me see if
I can do that
I am just going to copy paste this stuff
so let's say I do want to go and create
a a website I can go into
I'll just do this in my home directory
it will create a file or folder called
my site
and it's going to be of this website
type and I can go into
my site and you can see like it created
this yaml file there's an index.qmd file
um so it's pre-populated some of this
stuff for us and then if we want we can
either say quarto
preview
and what it will do is it'll find all of
the uh qmd files and sort of just render
them out locally and then you have again
like a nice little website that again
everything is a quarto file so if you
need to embed r or python code or really
both languages at the same time for a
particular use case like you have an
ability to do that and disseminate your
work
right so that is that is the end of my
talk if anyone has any questions I guess
we'll be open for for questions
[Applause]
just don't ask me about Shining
so is it um is it one thing that I
noticed it seems like um
create a document
it strikes me
as a different Darkness so
solve a certain type of ways
even within just
oh okay so let me rephrase the question
of okay so I have this Cordo document is
there a way
when you render it there's going to be
different output types but not every
single like parameter applies to every
output type is that like a decent
rephrasing
I
maybe I'll take another pass
so if like when you're designing and
creating a doctor
is do you have to be a very
this you
know
in this case
special stuff
presentation versus a website or
oh okay so
um do you need to like think a little
bit more about like
your final output type when you're
dealing with a quarto document
um if it's if you're in like the regular
data science pipeline like if you're in
regular Jupiter thought process which is
I'm just writing code I see output you
don't really have to think too much
about the output type assuming that your
output type is also what you expect at
Jupiter which is just a single
continuous document
um so in that case no the only one that
can be uh that might get interesting is
when your output type is a PDF because
there is like a latex conversion of
stuff that's going on in there but in
the yaml header there is a way to all of
the stuff that you would be able to put
into the Preamble of a latex file you
can
link to it in the yaml file so if it's
like hey I need like I don't know like
my code output to look like this or my
tables need to look like this and you
have a style guide from latex like
there's ways to link that in there and
that would only get called when you
actually call the PDF output and
likewise like if you have CSS
customization for HTML output like that
would only get called when you're doing
the HTML output so there are ways to
like tweak depending on the output and
there are like entry points for a lot of
it your mileage will vary um the thing
the furthest I've gotten with the PDF
output was I copy pasted my dissertation
put it into quarto and see if it like
and then put in like the universities
like style guide and see if it rendered
it got pretty far the only thing that it
wasn't able to do when I first tried it
was like the Roman numeral numbering for
everything before before the actual
dissertation started so
um that's like that's like the only
hiccup that I saw which is actually
pretty good considering like it was a
whole like a huge uh project
um the other thing um if you ever end up
stuck where you're like hey this
output's just like a little bit weird or
something
um
you do have the ability again to like to
save out the intermediate type
um so you can like manually like that's
not the ideal world but you could like
tweak things
um as needed so that's that's actually
what I did when I uh rewrote my um
and update to the book that I'm going to
be giving away
um it was written in quarto it exported
out to latex and then like
I gave that to the publisher like here's
the latex files like you're gonna lay
everything out on the page so
uh wait there was one person in the back
oh okay
uh so the question is do I is there a
way to Auto preview the markdown file
wait hold on uh
there's a preview has a markdown file or
do you need to render it
um so it does
trying to think
um I know in vs code there is like a
preview this thing
um so there is like a preview
the file itself is like very markdown
like so if you if your editor doesn't
support it you can always like
Pretend This is marked down like at the
very worst case like you drop the Q out
of the file extension and just let
whatever reader like read the thing
but again like the nice part is like all
the output isn't in there so you don't
have to worry about like some random
thing just showing up
um like cluttering or messing up like
some part of the output
no I
want to maybe
yeah for HTML
oh okay so now the question is
um can a single document work if it's a
continuous scroll through view or uh
with slides that have like different
pages I guess that is like one of the
cases where you do have to think about
what your uh final output is
um the good thing so I can actually show
you the source document for the actual
presentation
so this is actually like what my
presentation uh looks like so we have
um
a yaml header and Etc et cetera the
slides are actually uh like two level uh
markdown things so if I really wanted to
render this as a continuous document
it'll look pretty decent actually
um and it's really just saying like
these are just my markers for next slide
versus like big they get her so if it's
something along the lines of like a
document that you're using to convey in
a meeting or something or whether or not
that be a continuous document or a slide
deck I think like this format kind of
works for both but yeah it it won't
really work very well if you're trying
to like write a whole book out of it
having said that a single file here
could be a book chapter so it could be
written with the same like table of
content breakdowns of a book The only
difference is people expect to read
things in a book they don't expect to
read full slides of text when you're
presenting so like your type and style
of writing is going to change but
um it will render the thing and create
whatever you ask it to
yep
Google Docs
we do our code application
I have no idea if there's a thing that
connects to Google Docs so I know that
it can export to a Word document and
word and Microsoft and this applies for
PowerPoint as well you can create a
template file that when it renders will
at least respect how your headings will
look and stuff like that
um
so I know in there are packages that
will say like that are like Google doc
apis but like it's more like I already
have this thing can I just export this
out to uh like Google drive but I don't
think it's like straight up in Panda
work and just upload to a Google Drive
document like you definitely have to
like write your own little uh whatever
rest API push push command or something
to get it up there
is
other some document than this one oh uh
I haven't tried that uh
so the question is around like when uh
using includes which uh there's two
that's like a loaded term because there
is includes in late Tech world where
like you're including like like other
um
like sub files or something but you can
also
um in up here in the yaml header include
like CSS files or ways that you can do
that so now the question is like can you
do child documents I believe the answer
is yes I haven't done it yet
um but
if I am building off of like the people
who built these tools
um sub documents or sub child files and
all of that does work in the precursor
to quarto which was our markdown and
that works really well and I've done it
so I will say I believe it does I just
personally haven't done it yet
oh okay
said that you need to you need to supply
the python
python you also specify like a custom
yeah so the question is I wrote python
here can I like put any of the other
kernels I believe as long as I have it
installed you could
um I just know out of the box it sort of
like supports our python Julia and like
observable JavaScript like it's sort of
out of the box
um I haven't tested like
for example I know like
what is another kernel that exists in
like JavaScript like C plus is one right
um I haven't tried it yet and it's also
because like the nature of the work that
I do like I don't touch that so
um I haven't really explored that but I
know
um speaking with some of the uh authors
like they did keep that in mind so there
are ways to put that stuff in there I
just don't know how much of like of that
is working
um
in a quarter document specifically
I can try after this I'll put I'll try
to put together a demo that uses
some other language
something that like does it always have
to go through a notebook to say like
render
chunk
uh the
table
is fine
oh oh
um can you
can you just run stuff yeah I think you
can I'm afraid to do it
um because do I have an uh uh an example
hold on hold on we can we can maybe try
this
uh so here's a quarto document
and
maybe we can try this so your question
is like can I just say this is like bash
and then just say
that will work right
um so let's see well that will actually
work
Moment of Truth here's a live demo
without oh no
um do I have it to actually execute Okay
so
it should but
um yeah this is probably for me the way
I'm looking at it right now it just
doesn't know what bash is as a as a
kernel to run stuff in
um
now let me try to think
yeah you definitely have to specify some
other uh thing I know like this Jupiter
um parameter does have like other stuff
you can put in there like you can
actually give it the kernel and the
kernel whatever there's a whole bunch of
other parameters that I
almost really never look at because I
just run an RF python but yeah so if you
do have and I think like that's when you
have to have all the other kernel stuff
like all set up
um but I haven't done it so
um but yeah so there are entry points
where you can run arbitrary scripts
outside and just incorporate it in
um the other thing that I don't know off
the top of my head is if you have for
example like
a different language uh
code chunk
does the state in one carry over to the
other because the really primitive way
is like I just run the thing that you
told me in here do all your variables
exist again when you try to call it in
the cell below originally before quarto
and R markdown like all of this happened
that was one of the the nice things that
I really liked about just working in
Jupiter notebooks was I can just specify
the kernel and then it could just be
like a bash kernel and I can write like
a book or instructions on how to like
use git because it was using bash so
that was like one of the things that I
really liked about Jupiter um but now
like Quarters on top of it so maybe I
just write the whole thing in Jupiter
and just like render it out into
something that's like a little bit nicer
for me
yeah
we all go to lunch
[Applause]